good afternoon Brian said my name is
Chris Kolbert I'm a Software Architect
at continuum analytics and I'm about to
break every rule in the book by giving
live demo with an alpha product so all
the usual disclaimers apply with that so
Brian you know he kind of mentioned that
we consider Jupiter and the things that
Jupiter provides building blocks for
scientific computing what we really
wanted to do with Jupiter lab is bring
all of those building blocks under one
roof so that you can use them together
it's easier than having separate browser
panes open across different monitors how
different windowing systems all I kind
of stuff and so I kind of just want to
start by running through the building
blocks that we offer that are all under
this one roof so when you start Jupiter
lab you're going to see something
similar to this it's called our launcher
page one click to start a new Python
notebook if that's not enough I can open
a new launcher I can one click start a
Python console this is going to be
similar to a QT console if anybody's
ever used that in the classic I pipe on
TT console stuff we also have live
terminals so this is running in a web
browser using terms yes I actually full
UNIX terminal access inside of the
browser now and we have text text
editors these are kind of the default
kind of building blocks that we have
that you're allowed to create manipulate
inside of Jupiter lab but one of the
things Brian also said is that your
notebooks are still notebooks so if you
know Jupiter lab wouldn't be that useful
if we couldn't completely recreate the
the notebook experience that you're used
to in the classic notebook and so we
spent a lot of time it's a brand new
implementation of the notebook so the
notebook front-end is completely new
it's not actually the classic notebook
but it has almost all of the features at
this point of the classic notebook so
I'm going to open a reasonably complex
notebook at this point and it's all the
stuff you're used to seeing in the
regular chipper notebook we have tables
we have rich output we have math and now
we have pandas dataframes
but since the brand new front-end and we
were able to do things a little bit
differently this time we've added new
sorts of things so we can now expand and
collapse cells which was a big feature
people have one in for a very long time
one of the other features people wanted
is the ability to drag and drop cells so
now I can I can take a cell and I can
start moving it around the notebook into
a new position where I want it to be so
your notebooks are still notebooks it's
going to be a familiar interface but now
with lots of lots of feature
improvements and lots of more feature
and
it's planned because now we're built on
an architecture that actually allows us
to implement those and and build in
those nice those nice new features one
of the things that we also do a lot of
in beta science is writing a lot of
markdown so I'm just going to open a
little demo markdown file right here and
so you might write something like this
or you're trying to explain some sort of
Python data science it might have some
inline markdown examples and what you
might want to do in a classical workflow
is open a markdown preview that might be
and they new I don't know what's going
on with my alpha software here we go all
right let's try this again
when in doubt refresh the page
there you go so you might find yourself
writing some markdown code having a
markdown preview on another page and
switching back and forth and that's kind
of what we were trying to get away from
if you ever what Brian was saying is
that people wanted to have multiple
notebooks on one page or multiple
building blocks on the same page and so
what we've what we've built basically in
parallel is uper lab in a project that
I'm the primary author of it's called
phosphor jeaious it's a lower level
JavaScript UI toolkit library for
building applications that are like
jeepers lab so as we were building
Jupiter lab and we were finding that
there weren't necessarily JavaScript
libraries in the open-source world that
did what we needed to to build this type
of application with the performance that
we wanted we did what any
self-respecting computer scientist would
we went often built our own and we made
it a separate project so that people
that want to build applications like
Jupiter but that aren't exactly like
Jupiter lab they can do that and so so
one of the things that that library
provides is a more advanced window
docking system and so I can actually
take my live preview markdown and I can
stretch it to the side and I can
actually put it parallel right next to
my other documents and what's really
cool about this is that everything that
we're seeing and all the data models
that we have driving these markdown
files in the live preview they're all
interconnected so as I edit this
markdown file my live preview updates at
the same time so now instead of having
to go through a build compile switch
tabs look for my different you know
compare my output go back edit some more
I can do it side by side in the same
paint another new feature that we built
in to our markdown viewer is we can
actually create a new code console
that's attached to that markdown viewer
and it might be really cool if I just
kind of put this over there where I have
a little bit more screen real estate and
once I once I have actually a code
console attached to my markdown file I
can go to my little blocks of Python
code that are right here and I can shift
enter and send that code to my console
and have it execute and so now I could
ride my markdown file and as I'm writing
my markdown file I can actually test my
code and run it in the console and if I
want to play with that data it's still
there this is a live console so I can
you know I can type in whatever I want
to do inspect my data play with it in
the console and do all that sort of
stuff and I might this console might get
really big as I'm doing things so I
might want to expand it to take up more
my screen real estate to see some things
temporarily so we have a shortcut for
that
where I can just quickly snap into what
we call single document mode weird
obtain that I care about in my little
main docking area is the most important
thing to me at this particular moment
and so I can expand that to take up the
whole space but at the same time I don't
want the ability I don't want to lose
the ability to go back and see my
previous context that I was looking at
so what we have is a little tabs bar
over here that allows me to switch
between the other open documents that
are still in my session basically and
when I'm done looking at this single
document mode I can immediately switch
back to the same layout that it was that
and before some of the other tools that
we built into the system that allow you
to just get around the environment and
work with your data in a friendly way
you've seen me playing around with this
file browser I'm actually going to call
it now this is the file browser that we
have we've got some breadcrumbs at the
top that allow you to basically navigate
through anything that's actually it from
the roof of your Jupiter notebook server
anything that that server is serving up
to you we can actually browse through in
this in a regular file browser so these
are these are it's a control you're
going to be pretty comfortable with it's
pretty pretty standard things we have
the ability to I find the right file
here I have the ability to drag and drop
and move stuff around in my file browser
all sorts of normal things we've also
got a running tab tells me what sort of
terminal sessions with sort of notebook
sessions I have up and running and we've
got a standard command palette anybody
that's used sublime text or BS code is
going to be familiar with something like
this you can filter it to do things like
fuzzy search I want to launch a new
terminal those sorts of things will open
for you so this is all pretty well and
good and I can work in this environment
and I can see the data that's in there
and I can edit some data I can create
some things but what if I had something
that is a soup I get out of this full
screen here there we go what would you
do if you had like a 200 megabyte CSV
file now you wanted to open I happen to
have one of those on my desktop and I
think what most people might do is they
might just double click on it and try to
open it in Excel and I'm going to let
that run for a little bit because it's
like 1.2 million rows and it's going to
take a little bit for Excel to do that
and while that's going I'm actually
going to go find a slightly smaller data
set that I have on the system here
and we'll go ahead and open that up and
I know this is a couple thousand rows
and what this opened in is our new csv
viewer if anybody's used to the classic
notebook that opened almost
instantaneously in the classic notebook
you would have gotten a pager it would
have taken 30 or 45 seconds to load and
you would have had to page through a
thousand rows at a time what this is
this cool csv viewer grid viewer thing
is a new widget that we're building a
phosphor j/s it's still very much beta
there's lots of features that that we
want to add to it still but it's
extremely high performance it's all
rendered in canvas we can scroll through
nearly infinite datasets as my I think
Excel is not now so so 200 megabyte
excel file excels like sorry can't fly
can't load it completely so let's go
ahead and see what it did and it shows
something it doesn't show all the data
and as I try to scroll through it it's
really janky it's not a very nice user
experience so let's see what Jupiter lab
can do with that same file so let me go
up here so this is that same 200
megabyte CSV file it's going to might
take a couple seconds pulling 200
megabytes over the network and putting
it in memory
but it loaded at about eight or nine
seconds and it's a 1.2 million rose and
I could take the scrollbar and page
through it in real time so we don't need
a pager anymore we don't need any sort
of the clunky grid tools that you
usually do to deal with big data you can
just throw your entire data set that's
the data grid and render it and if your
data set is bigger than 1.2 million rows
I have what I call to keep me honest
example which shows a couple of
different things I've got a couple
different grids here got some streaming
data rows I've got some things that are
updating one cell at a time and but
what's the most I think what the most
interesting one here is in the top left
corner this is a data grid with one
trillion rows by one trillion columns
and I can scroll through that in
real-time so there's all right thank you
so they're still up again that's this is
like 0.1 release we don't have
selections we don't have editing there's
lots of stuff to do but the graphics
pipeline is in the high performance
rendering in is in and so we can scale
and we can still scale with a trillion
route data grid and have variable size
rows and columns by the way which is
where most all the other large-scale
data grids fall over so so that's kind
of where we're going in the high
performance data visualization grid
rendering kind of stuff but aside from
CSV files and fancy grids what are the
kind of support for files do we have so
probably a lots of things that you
typically expect go back to my data file
here I can drag and drop from the file
browser get some more screen real estate
so we have images or image viewer it's
got some basic zooming features in it I
can plus - zoom in and out and I get
scroll bars all that kind of stuff and
we've got support for geo JSON files so
if anybody is familiar with geo JSON
it's a JSON representation of geography
and so we can load that in a leaflet
viewer and actually have a map using
leaflet so that's all that's all well
and good and in the previous talk we had
mentioned Vega and Vega light for doing
graphics and so we actually do have
support for Vega and Vega light we
probably need to organize these things a
little bit better
go to examples
there we go okay so I can just take a
vega light file drag and drop it into
jupiter lab and I get my plot and this
is great but what if I want to actually
see what the JSON is that's loaded under
that covers well I can right click on my
file browser and I happen to have
another file opener that can handle Vega
light JSON files this is just regular
JSON and I can open it with our JSON
beer and our JSON viewer allows us to
view this data as an interactive tree so
I can actually interactively browse the
JSON that's making up this vague
visualization what does I mentioned
before the data models that drive these
so the data model that drives us JSON
viewer the data model that drives the
altaïr visualization all of those all
those visualizations are sharing the
same underlying core data model that's
running inside of Jupiter lab so I can
actually open the same JSON file with my
code editor do all three simultaneously
and if I want to go down and change the
marks that are rendered in this big
light file I can just type in my editor
and as I make the edit the plots going
to update my JSON viewer is going to
update and the file is going to
automatically be saved back to disk so
we've kind of tied all of these concepts
together under one roof and all of these
building blocks can now communicate and
act together and at this point it's now
good to hand it off to Ian who's going
to talk us about talk to us about the
next level of interaction which is the
real-time communication we built into
Juber level
you
alright thanks Chris
Brian you said you had a found it okay
sorry I'm not a Mac user usually okay so
so one of the most requested features
that we get for Jupiter notebooks is
better tools for collaborating with
people and to that end we've been
attacking it from several different
angles we're trying to add better get
support and github support into our user
interfaces we're trying to add better
support for diffing notebooks and
looking at conflict and looking at a you
know if you what what kind of changes
you've made to notebooks and there's the
third aspect of that which I'm going to
be focusing on today which is real-time
collaboration now all three of these
different modes of collective
collaboration
have one thing in common which is
conflicts and you could interpret that
in sort of more of a sociological way
but by conflicts I mean just if two
people are editing the same document in
the same place those edits are in
general going to conflict with each
other and so we we need some way of
dealing with those conflicts and the way
that keep most people in this room are
probably familiar with is get conflicts
right you have two different commits of
those commit to touch the same area of
code and you have to deal with those and
you may have various tools for dealing
with those but for the most part I at
least I mean you have to do them
manually when you're editing documents
in real time the conflicts you run into
or of a different sort of beast and the
reason is because the most common way we
interact with our documents is by typing
text and the text that we enter has to
be it has to feel seamless in it and it
can't have it any kind of errors in it
so if there are any conflicts that arise
and we have to deal with them manually
you're editing your editing experience
is going to be horrible and you're not
going to want to use our tool at all and
so we're going to so if we want to have
real-time collaboration on any kind of
document we need some way of handling
those conflicts correctly seamlessly and
extremely quickly so that's a very
challenging problem and there are a
number of different ways you can
approach it one popular way is called
operational transforms which is the
algorithm that underlies Google Docs
and it also underlying what I'm about to
show you today so what we've been
working on for the last several months
is a plugin for Jupiter lab which uses
Google Drive as a store for notebooks
most people have probably used Google
Drive but maybe have not dug into the
API much but it does expose a nice rich
API and that that API provides the same
type of primitives for doing real time
conflict resolution that you would see
in for instance a normal Google Doc text
editor so if you look at what I'm
clicking on here this is a an
alternative side an alternative file
browser which is currently logged into a
Google Drive account and we've set up a
couple files and we're going to look at
in a moment so this is the same file
that Chris showed earlier which is that
markdown file and I'll open it first as
markdown and also we run into the same
thing as previously it might be the full
screen okay
how do i exit full-screen on this okay
thanks
okay so this is the same markdown
document we were looking at previously
we've got side by side panels of the
rendered and unrendered version except
for this markdown document exists in
Google Drive and so you can see that
there are some edits going on in that
document and I'm not doing them right
now
so you see there's a couple different
little carrots going around they're
adding Python code that python code is
getting rendered in real time if I hover
over those carrots it will give you the
names of the people court editing them
so Chris and Brian are both in there
right now editing this document I've
also got a chat panel on the side here
Brian is giving me a little pep talk and
yeah so this is a this is a markdown
document it works pretty well at the end
of the day though markdown isn't really
our bread and butter or bread and butter
is interactive computing so let's take a
look at what this looks like if we have
a notebook so here's the notebook I
whipped up last night it solves the
one-dimensional thermal diffusion
equation this is the equation that
Fourier that Fourier worked on and when
he invented Fourier analysis we can open
up the chat panel here and Brian is
helpfully letting me know that I've put
the wrong equation for for the thermal
diffusion equation I've actually put the
quadratic equation in there so that's
mistake but in the chat box he's
helpfully given me a correction for that
equation so I can actually take that
chat entry and click and drag it into
the notebook and get the right get the
right equation in there this is now just
a regular markdown cell so I can double
click on it you can see that it's just a
latex equation there okay so now that
we've got the correct equation let's run
this notebook I'm not going to talk
about the specific numerical methods
because that's not what this is about
well interesting looks like we don't
have looks like we don't have the proper
matplotlib library here I think we
should be able to recover from this
particular error though thanks Brian
okay so that is again not something I
did there Brian actually ran the
notebook on my laptop over there which
does have the heavy correct map wetland
version and that created this animation
pushed it across the network and then
rendered in real time in this notebook
without me really having to do anything
okay you can see that the the basic
editing of the notebook is this is the
same style that you saw in the text
document here's Chris's carrot and he
could if you feel like it change or have
your D done that yeah Chris has already
changed it to a different a different
initial condition so if Brian runs it
again we should see it updating to a
different function oh there we go so
whereas before it was a sine wave now at
the cosine wave so this this project for
you know doing real-time collaboration
is still very much an alpha product it's
it's changing quickly but it can be used
today so if you feel like downloading
and giving it a giving it a spin back up
your notebook and then I'm in and try it
out let me know how it goes and with
that I think we can probably take
questions
[Applause]
one thing I wanted to mention before we
get right into questions is that
everything we've shown here today I
didn't mention it in my segment of the
talk it's my fault I should have but
everything we've shown today
Jupiter lab as an environment as a whole
as an environment that's designed to
accept plugins and extensions to allow
you to customize it for your workflow
and for your needs and so everything
that we've shown from the text editors
to the notebooks to the real-time
collaborations to the data grid the CSV
viewers the Geo JSON all of those things
are plugins into Jupiter lab there are
no more privileged than any plugin you
would write on your own so if we can
build the notebooks and all of those
viewers and everything you see on our
plug-in system you can build any plugins
you want that do the same things that
our plugins do they can add menu items
they can add into the command system
they can tie into the same model
framework all of that is available to
you just like the same way it's
available to us so that was really one
of the founding principles of Jupiter
lab is taking that hard and fast rule
and that nothing is special and
everything is a plugin so great so got a
few questions one is it we had the
impression that if you have a big
investment in current Jupiter notebooks
there's not much of a migration to get
them into the Jupiter labs yeah but
that's a really good question
two of the invariants that we've had
with the Jupiter lab project is that the
notebook document is unchanged so the
document format is completely the same
and the second is that the notebook
server is exactly the same and so the
the the Jupiter notebook server and the
document format remain exactly the same
there are some places that users are
going to run into some rough edges one
is that the classic notebook has the
notion of JavaScript output and a lot of
libraries we're using that sort of as a
hackish way of getting rich output into
the notebook that's not really going to
work in the the way that it did
previously although with our new
extension system there's actually a much
nicer way of doing those things so it
may take a little while for libraries to
sort of port there they're sort of
JavaScript output over to this type of
approach
a little bit of work maybe for certain
corner cases but generally not much
let's see well I'll ask a question I've
been curious huh so does the new the
markdown is it is the markdown editor
going to have a spell checker for those
of us who write a lot and are lousy
typist and spellers
that is a long-standing feature request
on both the classic notebook and Jupiter
lab and it's we're not quite to that
point yet but it is something that we're
aware of is a very painful point I think
it's going to be worse in Jupiter lab
now that we're making it more pleasant
to write notebook in this environment
right and so we're definitely you have
to think about that's already a problem
for some already let me assure you then
what so the beta is just in a few weeks
out is there a schedule to go to like a
released version and though if you want
to in the wild yeah so I get like you
know you can blame me on this one so we
are going to release a beta before this
conference and I found a pretty
significant performance problem in which
large notebooks on Firefox and I
basically said no to the beta until I
fixed that performance problem and so
you know no pressure on me but when I
get that done then we'll release beta so
I would imagine within a couple weeks
you'll see you'll see beta for the beta
for the beta yeah and then how long is
the bait like well so what we're
considering your data as one zero if
you're a user
so basically we're saying this is the
product please also give us feedback if
we if there's if workflow is terrible
for one thing and we've really messed up
the UX in one spot so we can fix that
for the primary release but really we're
calling it beta because we might still
break some API so if you're an extension
author then then it consider it beta for
you and not one dunno but if you're just
the user and you just want to write
notebooks and use text editors and the
stuff that we give you by default we're
kind of calling it a user want oh so any
bugs would be fixed in the next array of
whatever six months or a year later than
oh no no no what bug fix as soon as a
command yes oh yeah so we follow cember
so we might be at 100 but if there's a
bug then we'll release the 1.1 and yes
sorry and we've been releasing about
every one or two
weeks and I'm guessing that type of
schedule will continue so we'll be
pushing out changes after the beta comes
out very very quickly mm-hmm so let me
just check something there
oh there's question what local Westin
all right I'm really interested in your
collaborative effort
is there anything outside and it will
drive and then also what are the
permissions so maybe we should repeat
the question for the life the question
was are we trying to hit any use cases
for real-time collaboration that don't
involve Google Drive and the answer is
yes we're starting with Google Drive
because they already have ap is for
things like permissions on
authentication and they already have the
implementation of operational transforms
which is this complex conflict
resolution scheme so all that makes it
easier for this as a place to start and
also it's a use case that we think will
be useful to a lot of people beyond that
so yes but not yet so then there's a
question about for the notebook server
for the jupiter labs is it going to run
on the same platforms as the the current
two Pater's a milk book server that
we're using for jupiter lab is just the
standard like most stable release of
jupiter notebook we do have a server
extension that we add to that to serve
the the javascript and the front-end
files for it we're also working on
electron app so we'll have a native app
experience for jupiter lab that actually
just uses the plain vanilla jupiter
notebook server without any custom
extensions at all jupiter lab already
runs fine on jupiter hub in the
multi-user environment jupiter lab is
now installed on our docker containers
so if you're using our pre-built docker
containers and images it's there so it's
it's basically everywhere the classic
notebook is excellent thanks so yeah and
I see a bunch of comments that on the
Twitter feed where people are very happy
about many of the things
they've just seen was there another in
room question like if you have over 100
languages supported party internal as
something 75 100 isolated the question
was a number Colonel supported are you
looking any further than that sort of
having multiple Colonels ready got one
said mingling urging yeah so that the
question is have we thought about
allowing multiple Colonels to run at
once and the answer is yes
so one thing you do get in Jupiter live
out of the box is a much more flexible
system for connecting documents to
Colonels and so for example right here I
can click on this change the colonel and
actually connect a notebook to other
kernels so there's a flexible way of
connecting documents to Colonels I think
what you're asking about though is
multiple Colonels for a single document
we don't have that yet but it's
definitely something that's sort of
swirling around in our discussions and
there's some people that are starting to
think more actively about that nothing
concrete yet but it yeah like some users
would like to have a single notebook
with for example Python and are and the
ability to share data frames between the
two and that would be an example we're
not there yet
some of the work that Wes McKinney is
doing with feather and arrow I think
it's going to be really helpful in
sharing data between kernels and more
useful in performant ways but we're
we're not quite there